ANDY CHANG: Welcome to
SCC 208, Shared Fate.
In this talk, you'll learn
how Google Cloud is working
to enable you to move from
a shared responsibility
model for security
and public cloud
to a shared fate model, where
we as the cloud provider
collaborate much more
strongly with you
and take additional
responsibility for making
sure what's deployed
together is in the most
secure and compliant state.
A core component of
this ability to change
how risk is transferred
is providing you
with production-proven
blueprints
for foundational infrastructure,
workloads, and applications
built with Google Cloud
best practices and patterns
so that collectively we
have a much better view
and understanding of
the quantified risk
and the security
posture being deployed.
I'm Andy Chang, senior product
manager for the Cloud Security
team.
As we've seen with
many customers,
an ongoing desire is to
get started and operate
much quicker but with
also additional security
so that the value of Cloud
can reflect in the businesses
that you run.
The approach we're now taking
to enable and accelerate this
is building out a set of
opinionated security foundation
and posture blueprints to
automatically allow you
to leverage predefined Google
Cloud security best practices
for your infrastructure
and for your workloads.
This is part of the
overall Google Cloud
vision in security for going
even further in our partnership
with our customers.
We want to move the industry
and help move the industry
from current shared
responsibility
approach to a shared fate
model, where we're truly
partners in your success
and in achieving your goals.
And this won't happen overnight.
But the key pieces
are coming into place.
First, a necessary
condition for this
is that the underlying
Cloud infrastructure
is highly trusted and secure,
that we're providing you
with that secure
compliant platform as well
as a portfolio of security
and compliance products
and solutions that you can use.
The good news is that
our mission to make
Google the most trusted cloud--
we're well along the way there.
Next, we're providing customers
with opinionated foundational
and posture blueprints matched
to the type of workloads
that they need, which
enable you, again,
to build on top of the
underlying services,
to stack and build posture
blueprints on top of landing
zones, and which all have
Google best practices in terms
of configuration,
architecture, security posture
embed with them.
You're therefore able to stack
these opinionated posture
blueprints on top
of landing zones
and take advantage
of the knowledge
that Google's already
built around security.
We then take the next step
and think about taking
the blueprints as the basis for
end-to-end solutions to solve
very specific
business problems--
for example, web application
API protections, zero trust,
and BeyondCorp enterprise
solutions and security
analytics at scale.
By combining these
together, you're
now able to get the best
practices in a deployable form
targeted towards solving very
specific business problems.
Finally, by having
the combination
of the blueprints
and the solutions,
it leads to a significant
increase in the ability for you
to use consistent approved
end-to-end patterns
for complete business
processes and applications.
That consistency
and greater default
secure configuration and
best practice adoption
leads to a much more
quantified risk model,
allows us and you to better
understand the architecture
and risks of being deployed
in your infrastructure
and your workloads,
and therefore
allows us to take on more
responsibility collaborating
with you and enabling different
models of risk transfer.
As we launched both our risk
manager and our risk protection
program, this allows you, if
you've adopted these patterns,
to take advantage of some
specific cyber insurance
offerings, which
will allow you to now
have more options for that risk
transfer and risk management.
Along the evolution
path of shared fate,
in addition to changing how you
as customers can manage risk,
we see parallel
transformation opportunities
in other key tracks as well.
Today many customers
in public cloud
have complex experiences
for security and governance.
And we see an
opportunity for use
the jobs to be done
framework to change these
into much more consistent and
complete end-to-end journeys.
Similarly, many
customers in public cloud
have disjoint experiences
managing policy and governance
for both their individual
instances in public cloud,
as well as across public
cloud and on prem.
We feel, again, that
there is an opportunity
to change this fundamentally
into a much more coordinated
and verifiable experience.
Blueprints play a key
role both in moving
product security from a
bolted on after effect
to a built in part of
the underlying solution,
and also from moving
platform security
from a set of complex
configurations
to increasingly
secure by default.
As we think about the stack
from a customer perspective,
as we talked about,
we first build
on top of that secure core
Google infrastructure.
And with the next layer
of security products
like SCC Premium, Assured
Workloads, Organization Policy,
VPC Service Controls giving
you additional capabilities
differentiated in their
ability to help you manage
your security posture,
your visibility,
and your segmentation.
These form the lowest layer
of the security stack.
On top of this
baseline comes both
the foundational and
posture blueprints,
where the foundational
blueprints
include org policy, resource
hierarchy, networking,
access segmentation,
logging, detective controls
to allow you to take
advantage of proven designs
to build your foundational
infrastructure.
And on top of that,
the posture blueprints
cover specific sets of
services aggregated together.
And both the individual
service specific controls
as well as the
intraservices controls
necessary for the
workloads to work properly.
The blueprints come
in three tiers.
And they differ really in
their level of native support
and their lifecycle management.
The three tiers are
supported blueprints,
verified blueprints, and
compatible blueprints.
Supported blueprints are
created by Google security teams
and managed as products with
regular six month refreshes
and attestation and testing
of the functionality
and resilience, as well as
the interoperability testing
between them.
Verified blueprints can be
created by Google teams,
partner teams, or customers.
The key is that the lifecycle
management, as well as
a station fit for purpose,
are the responsibility
of the creating team.
Compatible blueprints
are just that.
They're compatible.
I mean, they can be
created by anyone.
And their requirement is that
they need to be from a format
and also a style
standpoint correctly
matched to be operated with our
blueprint tools and a blueprint
engine.
And finally, on top of
the posture blueprints,
we have security solutions.
And these solutions
address specific use cases
and further add the wrappings
of go to market collateral, best
practice, application notes
so that you can adopt these
for your particular use cases.
We focus today really on the
security foundations blueprints
as well as the security
posture blueprints
and their relationship
to each other.
We think about the core
foundational blueprint.
The key is to allow
you to start up front
with best practices embedded in.
It creates a better
starting point
as well for security and
compliance, as the security
best practices encoded in
our foundation blueprint
give you a great
start to be compatible
and meeting certain requirements
within CIS, PCI-DSS,
NIST-800-53, as
well as ISO27001.
In addition, they allow you
to implement key security
best practices and
philosophies core
to how Google protects itself.
These key principles really
fall into three categories--
first that all defense is
always executed at in depth
and at scale so multiple
layers of protection
separate something of interest
from potential external threat.
They allow you to adopt
the BeyondProd model
for deployment centric
infrastructure and the ability
to have a zero trust
model around both
the infrastructure
you build as well
as the applications you build.
And then also, they de-risk the
cloud deployment and adoption
by moving you to these
proven patterns that
allow you to move towards a
more shared fate relationship
between yourselves and Google.
To dive in a little
bit more detail
on the security
foundations blueprint,
it provides that
strong starting point
we talked about in baseline.
It's delivered not
only in documentation
but infrastructure as code
in deployable terraform
that automates, accelerates
your ability to use it.
It encodes those best
practices and can
be deployed either at an
organization level or a folder
level.
And it has a six-month
lifecycle refresh.
We deployed the very first
version back in August 2020.
The second version was
deployed in April of this year.
And then these three will
be launching in October.
And the posture blueprints that
we'll talk about build on top
of it are tested and
verified against it.
One example of the
security posture blueprint
is the one we're building
for secured data warehousing.
Secure data analytics
and data warehousing
are a key reason many customers
come to Google, as we're
differentiated in our BigQuery
product and the things
we do in data analytics.
As you can see here,
we've adopted architecture
that has the landing
area and ingest,
the data warehouse itself,
the storage and processing,
classification and
governance pieces,
as well as security, posture,
and detection for threats.
In addition, there's also
the optional presentation
layer, which in the case of
the blueprints we've built,
we provide an example in
the form of an AI notebook.
To dive this a little
bit more detail, what
you see in the next level of
detail of the architecture
is we've segmented this
into four different projects
within the BigQuery itself and
then separate set of projects
for the AI Notebook.
These projects not only
create resource separation,
but are also their
own BPC service
perimeters, which
allow us to manage
both sensitive and
non-sensitive data.
The ingest contains
the ability to ingest
both batch and streaming data
and then de-identification
of all the data so it can
be correctly classified
into the non-sensitive and
sensitive areas of BigQuery.
We manage the IM structures,
the data encryption, and also
data classification so
that using Data Catalog you
can have column level access
control of the BigQuery Data
Warehouse.
And this architecture is based
on proven production instances
we've built together with
some of our financial service
customers so that we have good
confidence that the scales
and works well for those
regulated industries.
We dive into a little bit more--
what is in the BigQuery Data
Warehouse blueprint in addition
to the terraform itself
and deployable instances,
it has a set of documentation
that comes with it around--
accessible through either the
architecture center or the best
practice site, quick starts,
technical design docs,
solution guides, the code itself
with the guide for deployment
of the code-- terraform code--
overview decks, licensing and
pricing models, public talks,
the blogs, and also application
notes for specific use cases
as examples to get you
started more quickly.
It too is on a
six-month refresh cycle,
with the first version just
being launched here in October
and then the V2 targeted
for a Q2 2022 launch.
Built on top and also available
as a standalone-- what
this means is that with each
of the posture blueprints,
they are first and
foremost able to be
compatible with our security
foundations blueprint
and tested from an
integration standpoint
with that and the other
posture blueprints.
But also, they're
deployable in standalone
in your own Brownfield.
And then they include
third party attestations
around the security architecture
design, the stride threat
modeling as well as
being pen tested.
And you'll see
what this blueprint
in Q4 being tested against
NIST-800-53 compliance
standard in detail.
When we think about the
controls that are fundamentally
built into the BigQuery
Data Warehouse,
they fall in three categories.
Controls that manage
configuration state--
as misconfiguration is one of
the largest sources of data
breaches, we
particularly provide
and code best practices
for configuration
of each of the services as well
as integration and interaction
of the services within the
BigQuery secure data warehouse
blueprint.
Behavioral controls
focuse specifically
around the design and
architecture of the secure data
warehouse to look
at specific threats
from either data exfiltration,
from privilege escalation,
from things that break
the segmentation model,
the built in, and then
environmental controls.
As we talked about before, the
secure data warehouse blueprint
can be deployed either as
a standalone, in which case
the environmental
controls are fully encased
with that particular blueprint.
Or if they are deployed on
top of a security foundations
blueprint, they inherit
the environmental controls
from the underlying
core infrastructure.
We're now going
to move to a demo.
We're going to walk you through
a fully deployed secure data
warehouse and highlight
some of the configuration
controls, the behavioral
security protections,
as well as the
environmental controls.
Here we have a demo
organization in which
we've deployed the
secured data warehouse
blueprint in its own folder.
The secured data
warehouse blueprint
consists of four
distinct projects--
a data ingestion project,
which includes Cloud Storage,
Pub/Sub, and Dataflow, a
data lake project, which
includes the BigQuery instance
for non-sensitive data,
privileged BigQuery
Data Warehouse,
which includes Cloud Storage as
well as the privilege BigQuery
Data Warehouse instance, and
a data governance project,
which includes Data Catalog,
key management, and data
classification through DLP.
When deploying these
into your own Brownfield
or on top of the
foundations blueprint,
you can plug in the
data encryption keys
into your existing
encryption key project,
logging into your
centralized lodging project,
and the network connections
to allow the Dataflow
templates in through
your existing system.
You can also run this standalone
if you want to experiment
and play with it.
And to do that, we include
two harness projects, which
supply the Dataflow template
and the terraform sourcing.
The security perimeters around
the BigQuery Data Warehouse
and the other projects
are set up as follows.
We have three
separate perimeters--
one around ingestion, one
around the privileged data,
and then one around
data governance.
In addition, we set up
bridges between ingestion
and governance, privilege
and governance, and then
privilege and ingestion.
If we look at the VPC
Service perimeter around data
ingestion.
You'll see it includes the
ingestion project and the data
lake, has its own
defined access context
levels, and specific
egress rules.
Similarly, if we look at
the VPC Service perimeter
around privileged
data, it captures
the privileged BigQuery
Data Warehouse project
as its own access levels
defined at egress rules.
And then the last perimeter
is around data governance,
which secures the data
governance project
and has its own
access levels defined.
If we look now at the
bridging, the first bridge
connects the ingestion, the
data lake and governance.
The second bridge connects the
data lake to the privileged.
And then the final bridge
connects the data governance
to privileged.
As you can see, we've
defined access policies
for each of the separate
VPC Service perimeters.
We've also used our DLP to
de-identify specifically card
number and card pin data so that
in the non-sensitive BigQuery
instance, they can be used by
lower access levels and folks
with more generalized roles--
separate from when there
are the actual values
are being used in the
privileged data warehouse.
We use Data Catalog
with policy tags
in order to further provide
column level control.
You can see we use
column level policy
tags for person name,
credit limit, and also
credit card number.
So we give you additional
fine grained control of who,
what service
accounts, what humans
can access these pieces of
sensitive data as an example.
If we now look at
the data lake, which
has the non-sensitive
data set, you
can see that if we look at,
again, card number and card pin
and create a query, you
see de-identified version
of both card pin
and card number that
is still format preserving.
If we now move to the sensitive
data and the privileged data
warehouse--
if we were to look at
the card pin data--
because I have the
right set of accesses,
you'll see the
actual card pin data
within the privileged and
protected BigQuery instance.
However, to show you that we're
using column level control,
I'm now also going to try
to query the card number.
And here you see
access has been denied
because this particular
user currently
does not have the IM permissions
to access the card numbers.
We can fix this by going back
and granting the permissions
for fine grained reader
on that particular column.
And now if we rerun
the query, we'll
see we get both the pin and
the underlying card numbers.
So we've now shown you
the architecture example
for the secure data warehouse
containing three VPC Service
parameters and both data
lake for non-sensitive data
and a separate secure
data set, which
has column level access managed
through Data Catalog policy
text.
We've now shown you a deployed
version of the secure data
warehouse blueprint.
And we walked you through
some of the key configuration,
behavioral, and
environmental controls.
So hopefully this
provides you a view
of how we're embedding
best practices in security
as well as the
architecture to give you
something as a reference,
starting point, and pattern
to jump-start your workloads
and production around data
warehousing and data analytics.
To learn more,
you can explore at
cloud.google.com/security/best
practices the range
of our current portfolio of
blueprints for foundation
and for security posture,
explore the documentation
as well as the terraform
repos that we've supplied,
and then download kind
of reference guides from
a step-by-step basis.
We'd highly encourage you
to deploy these security
blueprints into your own
example, organizations,
and folders so that
you can experiment
to see how they fit
with your environments
and definitely encourage
you to customize and use
the module as a
script if they create
additional differentiation
for your particular needs.
As we talked about,
these blueprints
are refreshed on
a six-month cycle.
So we highly encourage you
to also feed back to us
where you've seen gaps
and things that you'd want
to see in future iterations.
We can put that in the
backlog and many of your needs
may show up in future
versions of the blueprint
so you can use a standard
blueprint as opposed
to one that you've
[INAUDIBLE] yourself.
And lastly, we encourage you
to start trialing the Security
Command Center Premium, as
it provides an overall Cloud
Security posture
management around not only
your organization but
these multi-project and
folder-centric posture
blueprints as well.
Thank you so much for your
time and the opportunity
to share with you what
we're thinking about
on the shared faith
standpoint as well as some
of those core blueprints that
allow you to jump-start and get
started with the best
practices and patterns
that can help you
be more successful.